So, Chris, were you able to investigate...
...whether Skill Source had the curriculum offerings we were looking for?
Yes, and the answer is, "Yes, they do."
I looked at the budget and they're well within the allocated range,...
...and since they're the training company of choice, I think it's a no-brainer.
Excellent!
How long is each of these courses?
They're two hours each.
OK, so if we decide to move forward with this curriculum,...
...the question then becomes what is the best way for us to deliver?
Should we offer them one at a time, or say, a whole day of training to attend all three?
Well, from a director level perspective,...
...that's really difficult to release my people for a whole entire day.
It's really hard to go to training for just a few hours...
...and then be expected to retain any of it when you have to go right back to work.
In that sense, I do agree.
I think it might be best to separate supervisors from the workplace...
...so they can really focus on skills development.
Plus, I can see that improving morale, especially if you bring them someplace cool.
That's true.
I mean, there's no reason we couldn't do the training someplace fun,...
...make it something people want to do, like have training on a boat.
Or on the beach!